today I'd like to talk about tell her
there's no such thing as a martial
artist that's born naturally the martial
art is has to work hard at becoming a
martial artist the human being has some
weaknesses and finding out how to turn
them into being a martial artist take
years but for those who prepared to
pursue that path will get so much
pleasure enjoyment it will force them as
people good people caring people and it
can really change a person and the
personality of a person there's so many
different people do i cater for
different reasons and since that's the
subject that we talking about him love
trained and demonstrated on large venues
with lots of different arts all
demonstrating to the public and
afterwards when you get to talking and
you may doubt discuss how they only
think it went hell the demonstrations
when how the public reacted we find that
it doesn't matter what martial art is
very rare you'll get anybody who's
arrogant and things that they stole the
show most most people become very humble
and the older you get the longer you've
been doing it the more you learn but
it's a a journey through life not a non
goal may start off for : in the
beginning but
tell about the change you see training
hard physically hard your end up finding
happiness sadness you learned how to cry
you learn how to love you don't have to
enjoy you learn how to be disappointed
it covers all the aspects one would need
a particular style like you know that I
chose was after 10 years of doing normal
Michael normal Aikido it was the only
like you know that there was I was
taught in Cambridge in the UK and my
teacher said if you want to do more
Aikido and you want to go to the best
you must go to London then for that I
done my every Sunday I can't remember
how many years but every Sunday winter
summer I was there
funny other half class with me up in the
pub afterwards and of course if I was
driving I couldn't drink so I used to
drink points for inducible in the night
everybody thought that's very strange
and very funny in those days because
there was drinking driving about but I
decided I wanted to become a fit person
I wasn't a fair soul when I started
yes I was physically strong but not
flexible not fit and as I said in the
beginning nobody's born a martial artist
I normally find that the people that who
are very talented when they come along
to Aikido
within a few weeks they telling me that
he'll gray are kiddos and
they're gonna do all their life what
happens is they they surpass everybody
else and their techniques are better
than everybody else within a few months
there leaping through the grades and
they're really shining and if I wasn't
as wise as I am now I'd say that's the
student to pick and to mold into the
next teacher the next I was sensing he
could be the next so sensing she could
be the the one chosen all women in the
world that tongue Aikido is a wonderful
art sadly those people they usually give
up the quickest because what they do is
they learn the mechanics they're very
good at the mechanics of Aikido my
kiddos very very cunning there's lots of
facets to it you have to learn about
yourself you have to learn about the
challenges can you put up with the
challenges the demands that will be put
upon you so these talented people is
it's quite selfish because when the
bubble bursts for them and they think oh
well have done that that was quite easy
they don't look for more where the
person that struggles they keep
struggling they perhaps not the golden
child of children the other the odd
person that you get come along but they
stick at it because to them they are
finding what you should find and there
is enjoyment they know they're perhaps
never going to be the best in the world
but to them it fulfills their needs
fulfills or they expect our becoming
healthy they may be doing it for
self-defense they may be doing it
because they've got friends training
with them well they just like the
atmosphere they like to do something
completely different once or twice three
times a week you know you put on this
white suit you're you're you're not a
normal person that's walking in the
street you do a certain etiquette these
unusual to Western person you bow to
each other it could be like children
playing you know it's me could be
make-believe it's different things for
different people as a same there's no
martial artist that's born naturally you
have to work at it
the Aikido I was talking about the two
main styles that I personally look at
lays the aikikai style from the homebrew
dojo than the awawa style those taught
by sensi and my teacher situs NC I'm
going to talk about more about that in
the next session because I want to go
into depth about Aikido can look the
same whatever style you do meanwhile the
style is a little bit more static could
can at times look quite course it's not
not got beautiful big flowing movements
they they're quite smoke much smaller
movers it has a flow but it has a flaw
in a different way and I would say he
was pouring tea from a teapot
could probe work slowly and that's the
thing with a wah-wah Aikido it's a slow
process is a basic process it's when you
open a pack of seeds and you plant the
seeds it's the most basic Aikido that
you can find so it's not always they're
interesting to the past in the once the
flowers of growing from the seeds and
the lucky guy to me is more the flowers
something's still come from the same
seed but the person that picks them only
wants to enjoy the flowers they don't so
much have interest in planting the seeds
and slowly caring for them and watching
them grow and this is what I will be
talking about on the next session okay I
have no enjoying it so far please leave
your questions and any comments below